on va voir si il en rajouter des choses
depuis adore ça et prêts pour pêcher
barrière ça à leur nom ou sa bulle dont
17 à 20 aides ou annoncé pas une
carrière c'est plus gros abba d'accord
c'est une barrière derrière de pompes à
chaleur
peut-être les enseignes du pompe âgées
même s'il aimerait ça fait du poids ah
oui c'est premier lançait sa bombe alors
qu'il reste des trucs aux des cintres ah
ben tu vois cela techniquement il était
pâle haddaoui sérieux et une pile bonne
dépollution amène porte jeune avait déjà
vu la porte que j'avais eue par la
serrure à waimes c'est çà et là tu va
galérer parce qu'il ya pas d'autres à
zatta je crois ouais c'est du bois une
porte en bois et n'avait pas réussi à le
remonter que par la série avec enfin
conduit aux jeunes recrues qu non je
pense pas mais ça rigole pas ça vous pas
rien
bientôt nos eaux et les jolies tricolore
ouais c'est ça ou les tricolores ils
sont cools à à ses juges prononcent à la
che en reste il a peut-être à deux on
peut le faire c'est quand même moi si on
la tue parce que c'est vous c'est un
micro et non à merde sur bien joué on
voit les pros la lega va au plus ont dit
que je vais sortir il va le championnat
et le rapid eye va bien à temps la porte
est fermée il a aucune culture et la non
elle est quatrième à bien jouer la
[ __ ] il eut deux mi-temps le truc chez
leur mère
la bombe at à hollywood
où j'avais encore on les compte les murs
de contrefort ça non du coup va faire
vidéo de restauration de micro ondes
quand ils sont membres
auteur
mais là
non microbes opening qu'elle nous
réserve ce micro ondes
on n'a pas honte boxing c'est bien qu'un
bout d'chou au couteau
ça va mais bon c'est déjà bien une pièce
à part à combien ouais ça c'est un
centime est il mort mâchoire de faim de
vélo à huy
ça c'est morceaux de vélo draghi opinion
au moins aussi on vas tu as encore enfin
ça c'est clarens de la mobylette débat
du vélo auront selon le bit
moi j'avais déjà fait des comme ça ainsi
qu'à béziers c'est pas pour rien qu'on
appelle un habitant de béziers un
biterrois a et une boucle de ceinture ça
c'est sympa
après c'est dur à dater 1 mais bon c'est
rigolo
[Musique]
bout de centimes ouais ça a l'air
costaud plaques d'égout allait annoncer
une barrière
on va savoir
joli belle trouvaille voit ici aussi
c'est un classique
moi j'ai fait un tout en l'étant je suis
content passé en cuivre ou même parce
que ça arrange pas mais ça s'est chopé
grâce à tous les ploucs y avait au fond
alors pas à chercher quoi tu vas pas
chercher la star n'a pas compris le jour
enfin une prise h et plus n'ont que ça à
celle là la région je sais pas voir ça
c'est un morceau de tonneaux et bientôt
de quelques clics à champel 4 nages en
est bon
photo ay est pour rien
un plastique en plus ces fondus il est
en super bonne et enfin c'est utilisable
il dit des trucs sympas belle trouvaille
circulation alternée wade allait
ensemble il a peut-être raison et encore
un couteau il est long il vieux
cilaosien ouais j'ai un truc mais je
crois pour la secousse à quelque chose
de banal
d'accord bon bah celui-là est cassé je
fais il faut vraiment du pain wii ou
lame de rasoir pas bon signe
regardez moi cette beauté bobryk et
est-ce qu'ils les restaurants mais moi
je partirai sur wii zippo c'est un
voyant plus donc ça vaut un peu d'argent
tu crois qu'ils posent tous les pensions
que sur les collections
ouais en tout cas pour moi il restera
bleui les toits fait gaffe politiquement
ah ouais bah ouais ça sert on va changer
c'est cool ça parfois aller doucement
mais sûrement ravis parce que sinon
c'est mon sa belle restauration zippo il
a écrit des choses c'est un vrai hip hop
ways hip hop usa c'est génial ça mais tu
en dis pas plus ben justement tu vois
quand c'est de la qualité
voilà ça se conserve bien n'ont pas
donné de résultat qu'est ce que tu fais
rasta petit coquin un petit coquin
pouces trottoir à sa laisse faire les
pro tu peux pas évaluer un briquet tu es
trop petit les briquets zippo sont
garanties à vie donc on va essayer de
l'envoyer à la marque et voir s'ils
acceptent de nous leurrer par et même si
on l'a trouvé dans l'eau donc n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner pour voir ce qui va
devenir un cerclage un non-sens gens à
brûler dans le rhône au musée quand ça
ici avec le mobile est temps qu'ils
achètent
une météorite toujours beaucoup
d'autorité c'est ce qui coûte le plus
cher qu'on puisse trouver trois
météorites mais bon encore une fois faut
l'identifier
j'ai vu l'avalanche couple a passé un
accord au plus tard à pornic et choisit
alors est le grain ping sa tournée
ainsi si tu es bon on n'a pas été bon
alors quelque chose pour ce garçon brûlé
jeté dans le canal
ou alors c'était la péniche qui a brûlé
la porte de la péniche qui a brûlé
sympa
c'est aussi tu as band c'est pas parfois
tu fais une porte ouais moi aussi brûler
ça marche
la boj a bien voulu de côté ou plus
grands noms mais du coup on regarde ça
d'autres peut-être de cette péniche
avant celle qui a brûlé siala dérivés et
tu mets une porte comme ça chez trop en
vrai c'est qu'il est doux c'est stylé
mais bon alors qu'est ce qu'on a on va
tâcher c'est bien ça retire les sachets
a du coup je regardais ce qu'ils avaient
sous la porte
il ya plein de trucs ici j'ai gelé enfin
pas tout à l'heure à ces panneaux redis
encore teddy conne c'est pour passer
encore un pc gaming au [ __ ] moi non
mais c'est la balle a scellé cette
saison messi mais c'est comme ça c'est
l'écran il ya les charnières avec les
écrans ah oui j'avais sur l'envers des
charnières mais qui date des années 90
animaux super encore un ordi pas entier
il faut d'une vision encore deux
centièmes
ah oui non
au début
un cadre de vélo mais il ya une
épuisette avec un épisode est la goûter
à oui ça c'est bizarre et 11 h 15 les
prises de notes est morte
bush des dommages allégués le kit
comprend mieux pourquoi les patins du
vélo mais cet accident le tour de france
sûrement pédaler comme et des
tranquillisants
il doit y avoir d'autres châteaux oui
c'est peut-être les bateaux qu'ils ont
oublié on trouve énorme les gars ça
c'est du gros calibre ça désormais
futuriste sur les pistolets de la base
les terres c'est un outil mais ouais
pneumatiques oui oui je pense à ça je
respecte
au pire elle est énorme
belle dépollution voilà une petite
trouvaille est ce que ça ne serait pas
une caisse enregistreuse trop de
compartiment par compartiment
ouais c'est bizarre autant et son petit
sans trop petit ça c'était dans l'ordre
aient des genres de ses caisses à outils
ouais c'est liège c'est peut-être lié
typo est typiquement ça même époque
ça peut être une caisse boutique et un
camion ouais ben regarde tout cela ça
c'est spécifique quand même moi je sais
pas du tout à quoi ça sert mais mais ça
c'est ce que j'ai vu tout à l'heure avec
un sur les photos avec l'épicerie
thématique art est d'accord ouais ouais
donc c'est ouais les cartouches m'a
peut-être faudrait que les garder comme
ça si je le répare on peut le tester
c'est quelqu'un de référence c'est ça
une cible numérique est sera star à ça
j'ai testé il s'agit d'avions ne va pas
quatre à clément d'un voyage en eux
mêmes il doit rester tomber quand je les
ai traîné ça c'est pareil sur leurs
photos que j'avais peur
ouais ouais ça aussi ça y était
et regardez moi ça cette beauté non je
suis passé de l'ivoire keeway al alam
il ya peut-être moyen s'est du coup sa
part en reste aux moyens il est beau jeu
content et ça c'est un endroit où j'ai
tiré 50 fois encore c'est bizarre le
fait qu'alain tout dessiné dessus à
stoke ouais non allez c'est pas dessiner
avec des couleurs les voir maintenant
les bourses et un blanc mais oui voilà
c'est des reflets mais il est bon ça
c'est l'indien ah ouais c'est un style
indien
j'ai une partie du contrôle enfin je les
obèses heynckes comme tu disais met ta
manette c'est quoi ça dans une pièce non
non elle a d'ailleurs comme ça c'est pas
une pièce alors n'ont parfois pas vu
cette taille ces éléments sont immenses
les côtés a pas de marquage non attends
je pense qu'il faut débloquer là parce
que ouais en fait surtout les trucs
qu'on est que people c'est ce que tu
disais c'est la caste qui va quoi
faisant ouais c'est plein de fans
écoutent et rouillée encore une fois les
brouillards c'est dommage
donc c'est un travail de ouf pour tout
nettoyer ça c'est la mallette kombouaré
tout à l'heure c'est à mon avis mais
normal et ash ouais on a le pistolet
vous pourriez l'être encore ça serait
d'ailleurs
ouais carrément will celle du pistolet
non il rentre pas là dessus je pense
languedoc roussillon le vrai luxe c'est
d'être là on va voir la vidéo est
terminé pour cette écluse donc de très
belles trouvailles et dont je suis
content c'est le couteau surtout et
aussi le briquet qui sera restaurée dans
une prochaine vidéo
donc n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
laisser le petit pont bleu si ça vous a
plu
et la semaine prochaine